bonsoir esther benbassa bonsoir m avec
mou sur rt france qu'en avez vous retenu
de cette longue conférence de presse qui
a duré près de deux heures on attendait
certaines modalités de déconfinement il
y en a eu selon c'était une allocution
très longue
moi je m'attendais à ce qu'il y ait un
peu plus de d'éléments et là on a
entendu ce qu'on connaissait déjà
on n'a rien sur le déconfinement enfin
la période qui suivra le déconfinement
vaguement on a parlé des écoles et qu'il
faudrait ouvrir progressivement monsieur
blanchard a dit la même chose déjà sur
les tests on est toujours un peu dans le
vague
on produit des tests
oui on ils étaient 150 mille un test par
semaine et à partir du 11 mai cinq cent
mille je veux bien c'est sous les traits
et très profitable pour nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens parce que
là ils ne sont pas une
le dépistage n'est pas très très actif
et la même chose pour les masques que
j'ai été étonné
on parle des masques on produit on ne
trouve pas un seul masque dans le
commerce
je ne sais pas comment nous allons avoir
des masques des à partir du 11 mai pour
prendre les transports en commun brière
n'est clair c'était un discours d'eau
tiède et une sorte de dison de défense
du confinement le le premier ministre
venait sans arrêt vous nous dire
pourquoi ce confinement avait été
bénéfique et que ça avait fait baisser
le nombre d'entrées dans les hôpitaux
il a martelé cela en plusieurs reprises
et je suis étonné qu'il y ait si peu
vraiment d'informations supplémentaires
puis 10 / l'est
le télétravail il n'a pas été très clair
et oui les entreprises qui le peuvent
vous savez on veut avoir des éléments
précis on n'écoute plus de deux heures
quasiment et on écoute notre premier
ministre et il est toujours vague et
nous sommes toujours inquiets ce n'est
pas un hasard s'il ya que 46% des
français mais qui font confiance au
gouvernement
alors on a eu un long exposé également
sur ce que l'on sait ce que l'on ne sait
pas sur ce virus est ce que on a des
anticorps ou pas après avoir contracté
la maladie
ce genre de choses finalement c'est
aussi le l'inconnu qui fait qu'on ne
sait pas vraiment comment en sortir de
ce confinement selon vous il ya bien sûr
un colis il ya aussi les informations
scientifiques parfois disons
contradictoires c'est vrai aussi mais un
premier ministe de blade plus rassurant
et être plus clair plus net et ne pas me
brouiller l'esprit avec des chiffres
qu'on voit tous les soirs d'ailleurs et
des graphiques qui ne nous font pas
avancer et nous sommes toujours dans le
flou franchement et tout quoi une
allocution si longue
c'est ce et de la communication c'est
quasiment lunaire de voir que et on
n'avance pas voilà on n'avance pas et
c'est ça qui m'inquiète comme politique
parce que je revais excusez moi je
voudrais savoir qu'est ce qu'on fera
après le déconfinement toute la nation
est de savoir si on peut être protégés
pour se dé confinement et en
l'occurrence il manque toujours des
masques des tests et oui des
respirateurs là il ya un peu plus de
lits dans les hôpitaux d'accord c'est
très bien ça c'est très bien mais en
fait on peut aussi à partir du 11 mai
entrait dans une phase de nouveau de
pique
voilà bien sûr il a dit il nous a dit
qu'il faut bien sûr respecter la
distanciation les gestes barrière donc
oui tout cela mais on le sait on le voit
devant les s'emplit dans les pharmacies
partout on lit cela c'est très bien de
le répéter mais alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on ne
sait même pas si tous les enfants
suivront les cours au même moment dans
les mêmes salles dans d'autres salles le
matin une partie l'après midi une autre
partie est ce que les enseignants et
accepteront de d'enseigner dans ces
conditions peu propices à la protection
de leur vie parce que les enfants ils
n'ont pas et n'ont pas de symptômes
souvent mais ils sont des vecteurs
d'infection est est ce que les
enseignants auront les outils
nécessaires pour se protéger
on ne sait rien une belle grèce demain
en ouvrir un une des pistes est sûre le
sur l'ouverture des établissements
scolaires c'est peut-être de prioriser
les élèves en zone difficile qui aurait
été déconnectés des des cours par ce
confinement
donc certains territoires entrerait à
l'école avant d'autres ça vous paraît
une bonne solution
j'ai été très très longtemps enseignante
je trouve cela un peu compliqué à
réaliser et un peu discriminatoire
que signifie des élèves en difficulté
comment on va les trier comment on va le
savoir est ce qu'on va ouvrir les écoles
seulement dans les quartiers populaires
quartiers difficiles
voilà est-ce que les autres parents ne
seront pas compte en se disant oui mais
pourquoi mes enfants n'iront pas à
l'école non plus ce sont des questions
vraiment de nous sommes encore plus
inquiet quand on entend des allocutions
de ce genre on ne sent pas à rassurer
c'est ça qui est né qui pose problème à
mon avis il ya une seule bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on pourra visiter nausée
et bien sûr savais que certaines
barrières de protection obligatoire ce
qui est normal et mais à part cela
moi je n'ai pas appris grand chose et
ces barrières
effectivement pour ces personnes qui
iront voir les aînés dans les états il
faudra aussi pouvoir leur fournir des
masques et des protections pour pouvoir
voir ses aînés oui pas seulement aux
personnels qui travaillent dans les
écoles mais aussi il faudrait des masses
et de dépistage va à paris on a commencé
lamelle a commencé le dépistage dans les
ehpad
ce qui est une très bonne chose si les
personnes âgées qui seront dans les
ehpad n'ont pas de masque et que nous on
n'a pas de masse non plus ce qui allons
visiter les aînés alors comment on va
faire c'est tout ça est un peu
déconnecté
voilà c'est ce que je pense vous pensez
du fait que l'autriche l'allemagne des
pays comme la pologne 6 1 ont commencé
le déconfinement avec des mesures
concrètes et que la france elle peine à
mettre en oeuvre un plan
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce pays écoutez
l'allemagne par exemple à gérer à gérer
la situation d'une manière exemplaire
oui parce que ils ont ils les allemands
ont pris les choses à temps ils se sont
elles se sont affairés pour faire le
nécessaire et on comprend qu aujourd'hui
il ya un déconfinement parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup moins de décès que chez nous la
même chose en autriche
oui et puis l'allemagne par exemple avec
plus de lits que nous nous on a sept
mille lits dans les hôpitaux les
allemands ont 27000 donc maintenant ils
peuvent des conflits nés parce que il
avait les outils nécessaires pour
pourront essayer seuil et d'endiguer
cette pandémie n'a pas la pologne je ne
connais pas la situation en pologne les
polonais n'étant pas très
excusez moi mais dans la boîte très
démocratique
ils ont pu faire valoir la raison
économique sur les raisons de santé mais
l'allemagne est un pays comme nous
l'autriche aussi voilà ils ont des
conflits nés au danemark aussi voilà
parmi les mesures envisagées un rien
n'est certain pour l'instant un lézard
fipa a répété qu'on pouvait imaginer des
hypothèses d une un tracking par une
application des personnes contaminées ce
sera étudié à l'assemblée nationale le
28 avril puis au sénat qu'en pensez vous
en tant que sénatrice
je crois que ce sera un débat le 28 à
l'assemblée le 29 on sénat c'est un
débat on ne vote pas une application de
ce genre et qui pour être efficace doit
être appliquée par 80% minimum de la
population on sera bien loin de ce
chiffre
vu que c'est aussi une application
liberticide
on ne sait pas comment on va protéger
les données comment on va les détruire
et quand est ce qu'on va les détruire il
serait peut-être beaucoup plus utile un
vu le coup l énergie et que requiert la
préparation la mise en place de ce genre
d'application il serait mieux d'investir
plutôt dans les tests dans les masques
et dans les respirateurs et ses traits
ce serait très bien parce que parce que
vous savez c'est un c'est quand même une
application qui peut devenir facilement
liberticide et qui par la suite
comme vous le savez tout ce qui a été
voté en période
d'état d'urgence se banaliser et est
entré dans le droit commun et je
m'inquiète 6 été prouvé que c'était
efficace
je serai la première à dire oui à ce
genre d'application ce n'est pas le cas
surtout que en france il ya que 77 % et
des françaises et des français et qui
ont un smartphone et que parmi les aînés
les seniors le taux est de 40 environ de
40 44 %
donc cette application ne pourra pas
être utilisé partout
toutes les françaises et les français et
c'est un c'est un problème nous avons
une facture numérique d'un autre pp
alors peut-être investissons dans des
outils beaucoup plus efficace et le
résultat sera meilleur parce que le même
si c'est volontaire
qu'est ce que c'est le consentement en
période de crise si les entreprises
demandent à leurs employés ouvriers et
de prendre cette application de la
mettre en marche pour pouvoir travailler
dans l'entreprise
est-ce que c'est du consentement il y
aura la pression aussi la pression de
l'opinion
si tu n'as pas l'application c'est que
tu n'aimes pas ton prochain alors rêve
donc là le la volonté dans ce genre de
de doughty est difficile à cerner voilà
en gros mais quelques dix jours la
marque ce sujet on suivra ce débat merci
beaucoup esther benbassa d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur arte france
merci à vous